Continuing our discussion of all the different components, concepts, constructs and models
that we have.
Continuing our discussion of all the different components, concepts, constructs and models that
we have within computer systems, let's now talk about the concept of the ring protection
model.
So here's the idea behind this.
Within any modern computing system, we have all sorts of different layers of software.
At the heart of the system, we have the system kernel.
This is the core of the operating system.
That system kernel kernel is going to connect to different drivers and libraries to create
the operating system.
And on top of that, you're going to be running programs.
And the idea behind the ring protection model is to assign these different essentially
layers, these rings of hardware, different levels of trust.
And the idea being the more valuable, the more trust that's required for one of the rings,
the more controls, protection mechanisms you're going to want to have.
And as you radiate outwards to less and less trusted, less and less value pieces of the
system, you're going to have less controls in place.
That's the idea behind the ring protection model.
Now ring zero, the center, is always known as where the system kernel runs.
So you will call the system kernel as the core, the heart of an operating system.
And this is the most important piece of software on a system.
It's what controls access to everything.
It's what controls everything, essentially, it's the most important part.
So it runs at ring zero.
And this is obviously where we're going to have the greatest level of trust, the most
controls in place to protect this very valuable and important system kernel.
Now the next two rings, ring one and ring two, don't worry about what they cover, what
they do.
The reason I'm telling you that is that in the industry, if you look at Windows Unix,
Linux, Mac, there's no consistency on what these two rings are used for.
So you won't get questions on the exam.
You might be asked what's at ring zero to which you will answer the system kernel.
And you might get questions about ring three, because ring three is always where your
user programs run.
So this is the idea of the ring protection model.
You rate eight outwards at the center, ring zero is where you have the most trust.
And you rate eight outwards to layer three, ring three where you have the least trust.
Next, let's talk about the concept of secure memory management.
And this is the idea that in a system, we'll have multiple programs running.
And each of those programs will have some data loaded into volatile memory, RAM, random
access memory.
And the idea behind secure memory management is that we want to make sure that if, if
process A is accessing data in RAM, what data should be allowed to access?
Only its own data.
That's the idea of secure memory management.
You allocate parts of memory to different processes.
And then you have a component in place system that's controlling and making sure that only
process A can access process A's data in memory.
What do you think we would fundamentally call that system that's mediating that access?
That would be a security kernel.
So secure memory management is about essentially implementing a security kernel that controls
which processes can access, which data in RAM.
And as you can see here in the diagram, process A can only access process A's data and not
data from the operating system or other processes.
Next we have the concept of data hiding.
And this is the idea that we can have data at different levels of confidentiality or value.
And the idea behind data hiding is that if you are at a lower level of confidentiality,
then you cannot see data at higher levels.
That data is hidden from you.
And so data hiding is basically just an implementation of which model that John talked about.
Which model had to do with confidential data at different layers?
And so Bella Padula is essentially what data hiding is all about.
If you're down at a lower level of secrecy, you can't see data at higher levels of secrecy.
The last piece we'll talk about in this section is what is known as code signing and validation.
And this actually relies on a lot of cryptographic technologies and techniques that we haven't
talked about yet like hashing and digital signatures and so forth.
So don't worry about the technical pieces of how this actually works.
Just understand what we use code signing and validation for.
And later on, we'll explain how this actually gets done.
So here's what you use code signing and validation for.
And let me use a modern phone, something like an iPhone as an example.
So we've all got phones, something like this.
And you probably notice that every so often you get a little nudge from Apple saying,
hey, you need to update your device.
Hey, hey, and what you're going to go and do is you're going to go into system settings
and you're going to say, update my device.
And when you've done this, you probably notice that when you say, you know,
you finally go through all the, you know, all the click wrap agreements and accept all
the terms and conditions and everything and you finally say, yeah, install the update.
It doesn't just install instantly for the first little while it says downloading.
But then when it's done downloading, it doesn't again just install instantly instead.
What does it say?
So if it took like 10 minutes to download, then usually for like the next 10 minutes,
what does it say?
Verifying.
Now, there's something really cool happening behind the scenes when it says verifying.
What your phone is actually doing is it's making sure that that software update that it
just downloaded actually came from Apple because if you're downloading an update to your
phone that's going to make a whole bunch of changes to your operating system, you want
to make darn sure that actually came from a trusted source.
And so if it's an Apple phone, you want to make sure it came from Apple.
So the first thing that code signing validation is all about is the authenticity.
You know who the update came from.
And the next piece is integrity.
If you've downloaded all this code from Apple, you want to make sure that none of the instructions
have gotten scrambled, none of the pieces are missing.
You want to make sure that that whole software update is complete, has integrity.
And so that's the two major pieces of functionality that code signing provides.
It allows you to know where a software update came from.
And make sure that that software update has integrity, so authenticity and integrity.
And the way that we achieve this is by creating what are known as digital signatures.
And here's the stuff that we'll talk about in a lot more detail in the cryptographic
section, section.
But you take your code, you hash that code, producing a fixed linked message digest, the
author of the software, then encrypts that digest with their private key, creating what
is known as a digital signature.
That's how you sign code, you create a digital signature.
So that's the idea behind code signing.